so for me like a woman's inch like I
don't really care you know what I'm
looking for I'm looking for a girl that
is then that is Pleasant that wants to
help me and then wants to help nurture
the situation that I'm in who wants to
give me a massage who wants who doesn't
mind cooking me something I come home I
work all day she's like Hey listen the
house is clean it smells good there's
food here your clothes are there and
when you're done I'm gonna massage your
shoulders yeah that's what I'm like a
guy like me but that's yeah and that's
you not they've been at the situation
what's the name of the guy in the suit
what was the name of the kindness that
was there last time gone it's another
most men feel the same way yeah no no
because when you say when you say it's
guys like you that's how most men most
men want the same if I wanted most men I
would have not been sitting here telling
you that I'm looking for somebody that
is intellectually Superior somebody like
Justine Wallace sat there and he said
actually as a woman also make sure that
you're well reading things like politics
and things like this so that you can
even be able to sustain a conversation
with your man Justin Waller did not say
you got to be up to date on politics